PROFESSOR: OK.
So we've moved on
into Chapter 3.
Chapter 1 and 2 were about
equations we could solve,
first order equations,
chapter one;
second order equations
in chapter 2, often
linear, constant
coefficient sometimes.
Now we take any equation.
And I'll start with first order.
First derivative is
some function and not
a linear function, so I
don't expect a formula.
A solution will exist.
But I won't have a
formula for the solution.
But I can make a
picture of the solution.
You see what's happening
as time goes on.
And so that's today's
lecture, is a picture.
So this function, whatever
it is, gives the slope of y.
That's the slope.
And it will be the
slope of the arrows
that I will draw
in this picture.
So here's a picture
that started, y, t.
And the slope of
the arrows is f.
And here is my example.
Well, you will see.
I chose a constant
coefficient linear equation.
Because I could find a solution.
So 2 minus y, I know
from that minus sign
that I'm going to
have exponential decay
in the null solution.
And then y equal to 2 is a very
special particular solution,
a constant.
And in my picture, y
equal to 2, it jumps out.
Because when y is 2, when
y is 2 the slope is 0.
So all my arrows on the y
equal to 2 line, have slope 0.
So that's a very special line.
And since the solution
follows the arrows
that's the whole point.
The solution follows the arrows.
Because the arrows
tell the slope.
So if I'm on that
line, the solution
just follows those arrows,
and stays on the line.
y equal to 2 is a fixed
point, fixed point
of the solution, a fixed
point for the equation.
And the question is, if I
don't start at y equal to 2,
do I move toward
2 or away from it?
OK.
So I can see from the formula
what the answer is going to be.
If I start with some other
value, some other value of c
not 0, then there will
be a null solution part.
But as t gets large
that goes to 0.
So I move toward 2.
Now let's see that
in the picture.
So let me-- I'm drawing
the arrows first.
So this is all time starting
at if y is 0, then if y is 0
then dy dt is 2.
So I draw arrows with slope
2, along the y equals 0 line.
This is the y equals 0 line.
All my arrows have slope 2.
Now what else?
So that's a few arrows that
show what will-- so the solution
if it starts there, will start
in the direction of that arrow.
But then I have to see
what the other arrows are
for other values of y.
Because right away the
solution y will change.
And the slope will change.
And that's it needs more arrows.
Well, actually it
needs way more arrows
than I can possibly draw.
Let me draw another
line of arrows
when y is 1, along that line,
along the line y equal 1.
When y is 1, 2 minus 1 is 1.
The slope is 1.
f is 1.
And my arrows have slope 1.
So all along here,
the arrows go up.
Those went up
steeply with slope 2.
Now the arrows will go up.
So I'll have arrows that are
going a 45-degree angle, slope
1.
Do you see?
I hope you begin to
see the picture here.
The solution might start there.
It would start with that slope.
But it will curve down.
Because the arrows
are not so steep.
As I go upward, the
arrows are getting flat.
And so the curve that
follows the arrows
has to flatten out,
flatten out, flatten out.
The arrows are
still, at that point
the arrows are still slope 1.
But it's flattening out.
And it's never going
to cross this line.
And it will run closer
and closer to that line.
And wherever it
starts, if it starts
at time t equals to 1 there,
it'll do the same thing.
And it will stay just
below the other one.
Do you see what the
pictures are looking like?
If it starts at different times,
so these are different times.
These are different starts.
Yeah, really we're
used to, at t equals 0,
we're used to giving y of 0.
So this is starting at 0.
This is starting at 2.
Starting at 1 would
be a higher start.
What about starting at 4?
Suppose y of 0 is 4.
That point is t
equals 0, y equal 4.
So that point is y of 0 equal 4.
What's the graph of the
solution with that start?
Actually, I could
figure out what
the solution would be if y
of 0 was 4, I'd have 2 plus 2
e to the minus t.
At t equals 0, that's 4.
And it fits.
It solves the equation.
And it's going to be its graph.
I should be able learn
that from the arrows.
So along this line of y equal
4, all the arrows when y is 4,
the slope is minus 2.
So these arrows
from these points,
go down with slope minus 2.
But the solution starts down.
So it starts like that.
But then it has to
follow the new arrows.
And the new arrows
are not so steep.
So the new arrows are
I have slope minus 1.
I hope my picture is
showing the steeper slope 2
along this line, and
the flatter slope 1,
or rather minus 1
downwards, along this line.
So it just follows along here.
Well of course it's just a
mirror image of that one.
It's a mirror image of that one.
I'm trying to show the
graph of all solutions
from all starts,
the whole plane.
Actually I could go, t
could go to minus infinity.
And y could go all the way
from minus infinity up,
all the way up.
I could fill the whole board
here with arrows, and then
with solutions.
And the solutions would follow
the arrows, the arrows changing
slope and actually in this
case, all solutions wherever
you started, would approach 2.
And that's what
the formula says.
But we get that information
from the arrows with no formula.
Let me show you a next example.
And here's our next example.
The logistic equation,
it's not linear.
So it's going to be
more interesting.
And do you remember
the solution?
You remember maybe the trick
with the logistic equation
was 1 over the solution, gave a
linear equation and expression
like that.
OK.
Time to draw arrows.
When y is 0-- so here's y--
when y is 0, the slope is 0.
So I have a whole line of flat.
I have a flat horizontal line.
That's the solution, y
equals 0 fixed point.
Also we have
another fixed point.
When y is 1, 1 minus 1 is 0.
Slope is 0.
Slope stays 0.
The arrows all have zero slope
along the line y equal 1.
So there is another
solution, which
doesn't do anything exciting.
It just stays at 1.
y equal 1 is another
fixed point, steady state,
whatever words we want to use.
But again, the real picture
is what about other starts.
What about a start at 1/2?
Well if it starts at-- if y is
1/2 half at the starting time,
what is the slope?
1/2 minus 1/4 is 1/4.
So the slope is upwards,
but not very steep.
The slope along
the-- and it doesn't
depend on t in these examples.
So that slope is the
same as long as y is 1/2,
doesn't matter what the time is.
y equals 1/2 gives me a 1/2
minus 1/4, which is a 1/4.
It gives me that slope.
What about the slope 1/4?
So 1/4, I have 1/4 minus 1/16.
I think that's 3/16.
So it's beginning
to climb upward.
So it's upwards again.
But 3/16 is a
little-- I don't know
if I'm going to get the
picture too brilliantly.
The slope, as soon it-- if it
just starts a little above 0,
what happens to
the solution that
starts a little bit above 0?
It climbs.
Because if y is above 0, say
if it starts between 0 and 1,
if y is between 0 and 1, then
y is bigger than y squared.
And the slope is positive.
And it goes up.
So do you see what it's doing?
The slope will just, if it
starts a little bit above,
it'll have a small slope.
But that slope will
gradually increase.
But then actually at
this point, the slope
is 3/4 minus whatever it is.
It slows down,
still going upwards.
y is still bigger
than y squared.
You recognize what the
curve is going to look like.
So there is an S curve.
It's an S curve.
Which we saw for the
logistic equation, and here
we have a formula for it.
Well, the whole point
of today's video
was we don't need a formula.
So you don't need that.
The arrows will tell you
that it starts up slowly.
It gets only-- that's the
biggest slope it gets.
And then it starts down.
The slope goes down again.
But it's still a positive slope.
Still climbing, climbing,
climbing, and approaching 1.
Now that's sort of a
sandwich in the picture.
But it could start
with a negative.
So what happens if it
starts at y equal minus 1?
The slope, if y is minus
1, we have minus 1,
minus 1, a slope of minus 2.
That's a steeper
serious downward slope.
So the solution that starts
here has-- that's tangent.
You see that it's
tangent to the arrow,
because it has the same
slope as the arrow.
And it comes down.
But as it goes down, the
slopes are getting steeper.
Whoops, not flatter,
but steeper.
For example, if y is minus
2, I have minus 2, minus 4
is minus 6.
So as soon as it
gets down to minus 2,
the slope has jumped
way down to minus 6.
So here is the--
it falls right off.
It's a drop-off curve,
a drop-off curve.
It falls right off
actually to infinity.
It never makes it out
to-- it falls down
to y equal minus infinity in a
fixed time, in a definite time.
And so here's a whole
region of curves going down
to minus infinity.
Here is a whole region.
What happens in this region?
Suppose y starts at plus 2?
Well, I have 2 minus 4.
So the slope is negative.
The slope is negative up here.
Yeah.
And this is the big picture.
The slope, the arrows are
positive below this line.
They're upward.
They were downward here.
They're slowly upward
in this sandwich.
And then up above,
they're downward again.
So if slopes are coming down,
and they drop into actually
it's a symmetric picture.
Really-- no reason not
to go backwards in time.
Where are these coming from?
They're all coming from curves.
The whole plane
is full of curves.
And these start
at plus infinity.
They drop into 2.
These start below 0, and they
drop off to minus infinity.
And then the real interest in
studying population was these.
Can you do one more example?
Let me take a third example
that has a t in the function.
So the arrows won't be the
same along the whole line.
In fact, the arrows
will be the same.
So if I have 1 plus t minus y,
that's the f, equal a constant.
Then that's a curve-- well,
it's actually a straight line.
It's actually a 45-degree
line in this plane.
And along that line the f, this
is the f, the f of t and y,
the arrow slope.
The arrows slopes are
the same along that line.
That line is called an isocline.
This is called an I-S-O, meaning
the same, cline, meaning slope.
So that's an isocline.
Here's an isocline.
It's a 45-degree line.
That's the 45-degree line,
1 plus t minus y equal 1.
Let me draw the 45-degree line
1 plus t minus y equals 0.
So it's a little bit higher.
OK.
Now arrows, and then put
in the curves, the solution
curves that match the arrows.
So the arrows have this
slope along that line.
Along this line, 1 plus t
minus y, they have slope 0.
Oh, interesting.
At every point on the
line the slope is 0.
Because this is the
slope of the arrows.
At every point on
this line, the slope
is 1, also very interesting.
Because that's right
along the line.
So here we have a solution line.
That must be a solution line.
That's the line where y is t.
That's a very big
45-degree important line.
Because if y equals
t, if y equals t
then dy dt should be 1.
And it is 1 for y equals t.
So that's a solution
line with that solution.
Now what about a line
with 1 plus t minus y
equal minus 1, a line?
If 1 plus t minus y is
minus 1, if f is minus 1,
the slope is negative.
So what does that mean?
If 1 plus t minus y is minus
1, the slope is negative.
So at points on this line,
the slope is going downwards.
Oh, interesting.
I wasn't quite expecting that.
Let me just see if I
got a suitable picture.
Why is it not right?
If 1 plus t minus y
is-- oh, I'm sorry.
This is the line,
y equal 1 plus t.
I think what I'm
expecting to see
is I'm expecting to
see it from the formula
too that as time goes
on, this part goes to 0,
and y goes to t.
I believe that all
the solutions will
approach this y equal to t.
I think their
slopes, their slopes
here-- darn, that's not right.
Their slopes should
be coming upwards.
Yeah, let me-- I
can figure that out.
If t is let's say 1, and y is 0.
OK.
If t is 1, and y is 0,
I have a slope of 2.
Good.
OK.
There's a point t equal to 1.
Here is 0, 0.
Here's the point t
equal to 1, y equals 0.
The slope came out to be 2.
It went up that way.
So along that line, the
slopes are going up.
Along this line, the slopes
are right on the line.
On this line the
slopes are flat,
and the curve is
moving toward the line.
I'll just draw the beautiful
picture now of the solution.
So the solutions look like this.
They are-- this is the big line.
You've got to keep
your eye on that line.
Because that's the steady
state line that all solutions
are approaching.
So if you have the idea of
arrows to show the slope,
fitting solution curves
through tangent to the arrows,
and sometimes having
a formula to confirm
that you did it right, you
get a picture like this.
So that's the idea of first
order equations, which
are graphed in the y-t plane.
And the arrows tell
you the derivative.
Thanks.